let's see i have such a different agenda
than everything everyone else because
the people they're trying to make a
living out of there trying to get famous
they're trying to get known and that's
not what i'm doing i'm reporting myself
from my descendants and when you have
that motivation it's different than what
other people live in like almost every
other youtube they always ask for people
to subscribe to them and all that never
once done that I don't care you know so
I mean I break all the rules but it's
okay because i have i have a different
whole set of thinking you know i don't i
don't need money i don't care about
money
not there's not many people like that so
in that that's why this whole thing came
to me because I'm different
the panel is the rise of the viral video
yeah in the panel is Saturday yeah
saturday at eleven do you have any
things you can share all that are you
going to save it for them I'm I'm just
gonna well I'm going to be doing it with
the people who did the double rainbow
summer the most popular one and they're
really awesome and we're going to be
taught what most likely we're all going
to be talked about what it's like to be
a meme and what created that and all
that and I mean I'm going to be just
saying all this stuff which is like like
I'm not I'm not what other people are
doing
I'm just doing something different
it works for me
here with me mememe it's a it's an it's
an idea that spreads the humanity like a
virus
yeah well I mean you know there's things
that you just know about you know like
things in in society are things in in
humanities consciousness that's like oh
I just know that you know I mean it's
you don't know how you know it it's just
everywhere you know and everyone kind of
knows that so I mean I don't have any
examples of it but I know there's I mean
if I brought him up you'd be like oh
yeah I know that you know what I mean so
it's just like I can remember in the 80s
it was like where's the beef right right
that's kind of like a meme yeah it's
like everyone that's in everyone stops
yeah so I'm not well seeing that 2012
this year no I talked about how
it was
that is what he came
come two thousand
Oh
I i think that the values that we hold
important now it's going to shift you
know and it hits been shifting you know
like people still buy Hummers you know
and I think we're going to get to a
place where it's like Humber is just
going to be a chunk of metal that you
know someone will trade a gallon of
water for because they're thirsty and
there's no gas with a hammer you know I
mean I think it's going to be that kind
of huge shift where the things that we
think are valuable now are going to be
worthless and the things that we think
are not really valuable right now like
land and water are going to be like you
need that to live it's really a whole
complete ship and what people find
valuable I think it's coming
well I mean I I think that's a very
distinct possibility that yeah there can
be it's going to be like goods and
services are going to be exchanged for
good other goods and services I mean it
seems like there's always going to be
some kind of place for money because
that's how you that's how you do it you
know but I think we're in now is so
artificial that it's gonna pop you know
and it's been a people are going to
realize hey this is a piece of paper and
what can I do as a piece of paper can't
eat it you can help cover yourself with
it you know so I mean yeah you know the
money is just an idea it's not something
that's real
so I mean I think that that's going to
be a factor in how people think because
they're going to realize this is a this
is only worth what a piece of paper is
worth which is not really anything so
you know I mean I don't know exactly how
it's going to come down but it seems
like all money at the hundred-dollar
bills it can't do anything for you
really doesn't happen trinsic value
unlike a boat or glass of water you know
that stuff a glass of water can save
your life you know our code can save
your life we're a hundred-dollar bill
can
you